an act of defiance in Putin's Russia can
simply take the form these days of
fleeing Alexander not his real name
agreed to talk to us on condition of
anonymity
he's just arrived in Finland where he's
come to escape the Ukraine draft
the majority of Russians feel negative
about the war the majority tried to
express their negative feelings about
the war in the kitchen writing on social
media in Disguise but Russia is a police
state it's a totalitarian regime this is
why people are staying silent they're
afraid of saying something wrong
what's up
but some people are taking to the
streets to protest against Vladimir
Putin's mobilization policy which is
becoming more unpopular all the time
[Applause]
the demonstrations are small in size
and those bravely turning out who
quickly arrested
but the fact these displays of political
dissent are taking place is significant
other rats are even more Extreme videos
circulating on social media showed
protesters throwing petrol bombs at
enlistment centers
and at this recruitment point in the
akutsk region in Siberia
this is the moment the enlistment
officer was shot at Point Blank Range
as people run the gunman reportedly
shouted no one is going to fight
for Vladimir Putin who met with
belarus's leader Ukraine is turning into
a nightmare
but Alexander lukashenko did try to
offer some comfort about those fleeing
his draft
some people in Russia started fleeing
abroad that Russia has a mobilization
base of 25 million people suppose 30 000
or even 50 000 have fled would they
still be our people if they had stayed
let them run
but this is the image State television
would rather present these pictures
showed patriotic conscripts arriving for
Duty bags packed and ready to go
the Kremlin knows it needs its recruits
to regain the momentum in a war where
its forces are faltering by the day
Alex Rossi Sky News Moscow